[Música]
antes de arrancar les voy a pedir un
favor que me miren con atención porque
soy casi una pieza de arqueología o un
dinosaurio rex depende de la de quienes
están aquí que no estoy viendo ahora
porque tengo más de 25 años trabajando
en medios de comunicación tengo arrugas
bolsas son los ojos un poco de canas más
kilos que a los 25 estoy más cerca de
los 50
tres hijos adolescentes y los vengo
sobreviviendo y sigo el aire presentando
un noticiero disfrutando de lo que hago
y para lo cual me formé y porque soy un
ser casi en extinción porque si ustedes
se fijan en los medios de comunicación
no hay más varones o hay más hombres que
mujeres si hubieran ingresado muchas más
mujeres en los últimos años siguen
siendo fundamentalmente jóvenes flacas
en lindas de cierto prototipo de belleza
no hay gordas prácticamente y de pelo
lacio y por eso me hice un poquito de
rulos por eso hace que seas un ser casi
en extinción porque todo conspira para
que las mujeres más grandes estén en
retirada
para que prácticamente luego de los 55
años ya casi no haya mujeres en los
medios de comunicación
y esto lo voy a desarrollar enseguida
yo para hacer periodismo me formé en la
universidad de la república cuando en la
carrera de comunicación prácticamente se
inauguraba y me preguntaba antes que se
trata que estás estudiando comunicación
hoy sea prácticamente esa pregunta por
suerte no se hace en mi primer trabajo
como no te dieran un programa de
televisión me asignaron un camarógrafo
que me gritaba en la calle porque no me
sabía parar perfila te para un lado
perfila te para el otro
y así a llegar tarde la conferencia de
prensa o entrar por la puerta equivocada
toda la culpa era mía por supuesto luego
también como notera en radio en mi
primera salida se imaginen veintipocos
años me tocaba cumplir muchas
notas políticas entonces me pasó más de
una vez que iba a ser una nota me
presentaba y políticos mayoritariamente
varones mirad apreciativa piropo y la
mirada risueña de mis compañeros de mis
colegas varones y muy difícil remontar y
hacer preguntas serias cuando ya te
ponen en ese lugar ustedes podrán reírse
pero en ese momento hay que poner cara
de piedra y hacer como que no te importa
por eso empecé a saludar con la mano de
lejos pilar teijeiro
también me pasó que ya un poco más
acostumbrada me toca hacer una nota con
baile
todos los días con un candidato a la
presidencia
éramos varios estaba en un momento muy
delicado esa persona
y dice una pregunta que no le gustó
éramos todos hacía lanzándonos y se me
viene arriba me acusa con el dedo y me
dice de cuando lo sacaste de donde
sacaste yo me quedé así en blanco los
varones al lado nada y son una querida
compañera y amiga me seis son fuentes
son fuentes y bueno ahí me salvó que
estábamos al aire realmente saliendo los
noticieros al mediodía en vivo salgo de
ahí temblando prácticamente claro mis
compañeros varones colegas de otros
medios me sentã discúlpame que no
hicimos nada si esas situaciones las
viven las mujeres si no las viven los
varones
y es a veces difícil de afrontar cuando
empecé hace ya también 20 años como
presentadora un informativo también
tengo que seguir demostrando que era
periodista y no un busto parlante porque
aparecía de aquí para arriba como me
decían los productores y me di cuenta
también que las mujeres nos miran mucho
más que a los varones
y por qué importa importa porque a veces
preparas una entrevista estudiaste en la
universidad y lo único que se fijan es
si tienes escotes y no tenes escotes y
está bien el pelo si te queda bien el
maquillaje si estás muy maquillada
sí repetiste mucho en la ropa los
hombres pueden salir sin maquillaje
repitiendo dos veces el traje todo el
año y no pasa nada y entonces si eso se
convierte en una carga muy fuerte en el
momento de salir al aire porque tenéis a
la normal y compartida tarea de preparar
tu trabajo
la carga extra de a ver cómo te van a
ver
o quedar señalada como una tonta o una
pregunta o si te reíste mucho hizo los
hombres quizás no les pasó a tanto
después con el tiempo te vas haciendo un
poco más
más duchas la piel se vuelve más gruesa
no le das mucha bolilla a todas estas
cosas y seguir adelante
usted saben cuando hay una presentación
por ejemplo en un programa que conduce
un hombre y una mujer o en un
informativo que conduce una primera
mujer digo porque a veces ahora están
abriendo cada vez más que abran que
estén solo mujeres o sólo varones
quiénes son los que abren el programa o
el informativo son hombres
o son mujeres que piensan pues
indistinto
a veces
[Música]
ahora qué tal cómo le va a iniciar
nuestra edición central mucha
información
hola amigos bienvenidos ya estamos entre
las nueve al mediodía y seis hierbas a
mitad de semana
pero además soy quien juegan el juego
[Música]
o las noches es televisión central y
américa noticias
buenas noches con todos vamos a
inmediato con nuestros titulares
ya no el action
trabajo a 40 generalmente está
normalizado que abran los hombres
es visto como natural que generalmente
son los hombres los que dicen buenas
noches por suerte ahora también hay
mujeres conduciendo solas y bueno pueden
decirlo o hay otro tipo de situaciones
pero es como cuando no sé si les pasa
que cuando ven un coche va a un hombre y
una mujer la mujer va manejando y dicen
el hombre está cansado
o el auto no es de él
o está aprendiendo a manejar es lo mismo
naturalizamos que los hombres son los
que abren y es una pelea que hay que
darla
por ejemplo yo durante 10 años hice un
noticiero sola que la verdad que está
bastante inédito claro en un canal
chiquito canal cable tv ciudad que no
haya más opción que yo tenía que decir
buenas noches en un momento un cambio de
formato después de esos años y bueno un
hombre una mujer el formato tradicional
y perdí el privilegio de decir buenas
noches ellos siempre me pregunté qué
materia había reprobado en facultad para
dejar de decir buenas noches
y si lo planteas porque me paso más acá
con otro compañero digo perdón pero
vamos a hablar cómo hacemos quién abre
quién no eso no importa cómo no importa
entonces abro yo no
las soluciones hubo por su parte la
brilló después no
por decisiones de dirección ahora con mi
compañero de pantalla es igualitario
hicimos un trato a nosotros 11 día 1 día
otro justo y está bien
está bien que soy así
y no es que solo pase por ejemplo en la
televisión pasan todos los medios
ustedes ven las columnas de opinión y
son básicamente firmadas por varones son
muy pocas las mujeres que firman las
columnas de opinión y no sólo pasa acá
pasan todo el mundo les cuento porque
esto viene a cuento de este congreso que
se celebró hace un año poco en el león
españa que la convocatoria del congreso
del columnismo de periodistas de opinión
sólo ustedes ven buenos nombres de
hombres era la invitación y entonces un
grupo de periodistas y de lectoras
dijeron bueno pero hay muchas y muy
buenas mujeres que dan que hacen
escriben con unas de opinión y empezaron
una una campaña que fue para secreto
bien acá
y empezaron una campaña en las redes
sociales diciendo hay mujeres
columnistas los organizadores dijeron
vos exageradas en el planteo restaron
importancia diciendo bueno esto fue un
detalle que se nos escapó el no poner
hombres en la invitación y por supuesto
que lo trataron de arreglar pero dijeron
que eran exageradas y que no eran
machistas y que no estaban de acuerdo
con las cuotas
pero lo reglado
y usted se preguntará si esto es
importante no estar señaladas en los dos
o tres lugares que uno puede llegar a
tener en esto y es importante porque el
poder de lo simbólico es importante
porque es lo que no se nombra no existe
el lenguaje crea realidades la imagen
crea mundos el lenguaje crea mundos crea
realidades entonces si no hay mujeres
las mujeres no sirven para esto o no ni
siquiera están en el horizonte
por eso es importante plantearnos estas
cosas y desnaturalizar las y estas son
esas imágenes mentales que de tanto
repetir
se fortalecen en nuestra mente como
sociedad en todos nosotros
y se conforma lo que nosotros decimos
cómo hay esta imagen es lo mismo cuando
somos cuando las mujeres cumplen
mundiales mujeres en la foto principal
tapas que mujeres pero las fotos que se
hagan en los medios son mayoría varones
es lo mismo no estamos no estamos
destacadas como en la vanguardia de la
intelectualidad como formadores de
opinión
pero hablando a esto de lo que decía lo
de esas imágenes que se nos crean que
son globales que son de sociedades de
cómo conocemos y nos ubicamos en el
mundo están los estereotipos y los
medios de comunicación son grandes
reforzadores de esos estereotipos no los
inventan están en la sociedad nosotros
lo tomamos y lo amplifica vamos
y no que sean malos los estereotipos
porque nos ayudan a conocer el mundo
porque si uno piensa en madre por
ejemplo todos tenemos una idea de lo que
es ser una madre aunque todos tengamos
ideas o imágenes distintas en la cabeza
hay ciertas características que nos
ayudan a entender de qué hablamos cuando
hablamos de una mamá o de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de un hombre o de lo que
hablamos de un padre
o de lo que cuando decimos mujer pero a
veces esos estereotipos se conforman en
barreras porque si no te ajustas a ese
estereotipo
que hacia fuera parece raro
y hay gente esa es una buena noticia que
puede desafiar esos estereotipos y
tenemos casos queridos cercanos y
realmente para levantar banderas eso le
dio la presencia bien televisión canaria
el roma y el primer día puede ser una
prueba diferente que mira y me dice así
escucha
mira canario con la cara que tenía como
te vestís tomás mata y fumar
acá no dura 20 días pintura en youtube
[Música]
los estereotipos a veces son negativos
para los hombres o para las mujeres en
el momento ahora uno ve la televisión
por ejemplo hombres sin saco sin corbata
pero en ese momento realmente fue una
revolución que saliera de camisa de zinc
con esos lentes una persona común
diciendo vecino vecina y ahora lo usa
todo el mundo en ese momento no
traigan sólidos entonces la gente un
poco más fácil culta decía por eso en
tele
y quién no sostuvo amar
lo sostuvo la gente eso digo los medios
de comunicación responde mucho a la
gente ya lo que la gente
digamos pueda sostener ya y apoyar todo
esto y para círculo de los estereotipos
el 52% de la población mundial
adivinen que son mujeres el 70 por
ciento de quienes egresan en carreras de
periodismo a nivel mundial son mujeres
igual seguimos siendo minoría las
redacciones de los medios de
comunicación
el 23 por ciento de quienes ocupan
lugares de coordinación o dirección en
medios de comunicación son mujeres 23
por ciento dirán que importa importa y
muchos porque son los que deciden qué
notas cubrir a quién entrevistar
qué historias contadas
y si vemos por ejemplo en las
presentaciones de los presentadores hay
prácticamente vanidad de hombres y
mujeres pero lo que dice al principio
una sobrerrepresentación de las mujeres
más jóvenes una subrepresentación de las
mujeres de cincuenta sesenta y una
completa digo si no hay mujeres de 65
años como que no tuvieran trayectorias
para seguir aunque esto ya dando opinión
y si hablamos de eso desde quienes
trabajan en los medios pero si hablamos
de quienes se ven en las noticias
solo 24 por ciento de las noticias que
ustedes abren los diarios miran en la
tele o escuchan en la radio son mujeres
y cuando aparecen mujeres en ese menor
porcentaje
aparecen como testimonios o víctimas
la principal fuente de información en
los medios en las noticias son hombres y
no cualquier tipo de hombre
son altos funcionarios gubernamentales o
políticos imagínense mediana edad
trajeado corbata blancos
acá para que dé un paso más y
heterosexuales la imagen dios
y esto que puede qué importancia puede
tener me pueden decir ustedes tienen
mucha importancia porque si nosotros no
vemos el número que decía si no vemos
historias positivas de mujeres y las
vemos sólo en situaciones de víctimas de
testimonios como madre de hija de
testigos de no podemos construir
historias positivas no podemos tener a
mujeres como referentes de cualquier
cosa no podemos pensar en mujeres
científicas si no las vemos en mujeres
políticas y no las vemos porque después
cuando aparece alguna decimos que no da
la talla porque no estamos acostumbradas
a que estén en ese rol que habitualmente
vemos en los hombres y en cierta manera
de actuar
pero no quiero quedarme solo con lo
negativo hay mucho que decir
de estos últimos 20 años
cuando yo empecé en la redacción eran
mayoría varones hoy son mayoría mujeres
se habla de otras cosas antes se hablaba
sólo de mujeres y ahora también se habla
de varones y de temas comunes que se
pueden hablar de de cualquier cosa
también podemos seguir investigando y
logrando primicias no tomando un whisky
a la salida de la redacción o al término
del parlamento
podemos buscar noticias de otra manera
podemos buscar otras historias no porque
las mujeres seamos mejores no tenemos
una mirada diferente y eso es lo que
tenemos que apuntar a empoderar también
a mujeres mujeres reales como modelos
positivos hay mujeres conductoras
potentes las vemos acá en uruguay en
televisión las vemos también en radio
conduciendo programas políticos que
antes no sé si los más veteranos
acuerdan impensables las mujeres
aparecemos en un rol absolutamente
secundario
tenemos mucho por hacer igual muchos
desafíos se ha logrado mucho el tema
está sobre la mesa pero si ustedes
quieren tienen hijas
por las futuras generaciones también
pensemos en que hay que dar modelos
reales de mujeres reales que ellas
puedan soñar ser lo que quieran sin
restricciones lo tenemos que hacer desde
los medios de comunicación buscando
diversidad de fuentes y eso lo hemos
hecho hemos cambiado un poco también las
mujeres en eso buscando mujeres
también como idóneas y profesionales y
también ustedes tratando de
desnaturalizar esas desigualdades
quitándole carga también a los varones
que están solo ubicados en ciertos
espacios de lo público
pero sobre todo también proporcionando
lo más más diversidad que haya hombres
que haya mujeres que haya mujeres y
hombres gordos flacos que hayan personas
heterosexuales que sean gays que hacen
lo que sea que hayan blancos que hayan
negros vamos a hacer una sociedad más
informada porque vamos a hablar de temas
de todos porque hoy hablamos de algunos
temas nosotros no los vemos porque no
les damos a veces cabida tenemos mucho
por hacer y bueno creo que está en todos
hacer que podamos soñar una mejor
sociedad y sobre todo para las niñas que
hoy tengan también modelos positivos de
mujeres firmes realistas y empoderadas
gracias